aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre des
Français sont plus que jamais attachés
alors commune la crise des gilets jaunes
la crise sanitaire sont passées par là
et ont démontré l'importance de ces 500
000 élus qui travaillent qui
administrent leurs communes les maires
et leurs adjoints les conseils
municipaux bien souvent tous ces élus
sont bénévoles et font même beaucoup les
travaux à titre gracieux rappelons-nous
ce couple mère préfet le premier
ministre Jean Castex vantait le mérite
des mers comme des piliers de la
République on les applaudissait pour
leur implication mais aujourd'hui face
au poids des finances publiques on
voudrait les sacrifier je voudrais vous
dire Monsieur le Ministre que votre
réponse ne m'a pas convaincu alors je
repose ma question allez vous faire
payer aux petites communes le laxisme
budgétaire du gouvernement en les
supprimer